today we're going to talk about the
question how do we know about numbers
when we ask how do we know about people
or trees or any stuff like this it's
kind of obvious you go out there and you
look at it or you go and ask an expert
who goes and looks at it and the expert
tells you about it the numbers or other
mathematical entities like sets or
functions they're not out there like
that you can't go and look at them you
can't listen to them you can't go and
see a film about them so that's how we
get stuck with this question how do we
interact with them how can we kind of
get our hands on numbers in a way that
gives us information about them the way
you find out about the world in nearly
every case is by having some kind of
physical causal interaction either you
see it you hear it you smell it or
someone who's done those things tells
you about it that's all a causal
interaction but numbers at least or most
people's theory they're not physical
things they don't causally interact with
us so that raises the question if you
don't interact with them causally how
nurse do you find out about them do you
know the answer to the question I guess
I don't know the answer but let me tell
you about some answer the people have
come up with so here's one answer
numbers are out there in the world
they're really stuff we make up in our
heads
the idea is numbers of these things that
we construct in our own minds it's a
special thing about human minds that
allows us to construct numbers and other
bits to do with maths if that theory
works it's got a really nice art to the
question how do we know about numbers
well it's because we've just made them
up in our minds we know about the stuff
in our own minds numbers are in our
minds so that's how we know that numbers
that goes by the name platonism Plato
thought that properties like redness and
justice and goodness exist but not in
the physical world they exist in the
world of forms place of ism about
mathematics is kind of like that it's
saying that these things really exist
but they're non-physical things so you
might think that fictional entities like
Sherlock Holmes
or mythical entities like Pegasus they
exist in our imaginations and our minds
in the minds of authors and then they
get passed on to the minds of readers so
that analogy between on the one hand
fictional entities like Sherlock Holmes
and on the other hand numbers being
happen yeah being creations in the mind
that gives you some clue to why this
theory about numbers has problems
because on the one hand it's really
obvious to fit yet one day somebody came
along and invented Sherlock Holmes it
doesn't seem like somebody just came
along and invented the number seven
there's always been the number seven at
least that's what I think there's always
been seven things so how could there
have not been the number seven so
imagine we rewind the clock way back to
the days of dinosaurs and suppose the
dinosaurs aren't that clever they don't
really have any conscious experiences if
you've got 24 dinosaurs roaming around
it seems that there's 24 of something so
you've got to have the number 24 so if
we're not there to be thinking about it
it seems that you can have numbers
without human minds thinking about those
numbers you don't think that numbers are
a human-made tool you think they're
beyond that I think if this theory was
to run it has to be made a bit cleverer
but there's a way to do that and that's
to think of numbers as not as things
that we actually create in our minds but
rather you think about a number as the
potential for us to do something the
idea is something like this even before
humans came along there was always the
potential for us to start counting going
our there's three trees there's 24
dinosaurs if that potentials there then
the numbers are there that's how that
theory goes here's a completely
different way of thinking about the
matter what do we do when we do maths
well we look at some equations and we go
through them and we try and solve them
we look at some axioms we try and prove
some stuff we talk to mathematicians and
they do some squiggles on the board so
here's an idea
mathematics numbers really it just is
about
those equations those axioms so on this
view there really isn't anything to
numbers beyond the kind of symbolism we
have for them this kind of theory it's
got the same kind of problems that I
just talked about obviously there was a
time before we had any kind of symbolism
you know before we were around so how
would you then explain numerical facts
about the past so these guys if they're
going to try make this theory work they
have to somehow explain when we describe
the past those twenty-four dinosaurs
we're kind of using symbolism to do it
we'd write down the number 24 or we'd
make the sound 24 so even when we're
describing the past we're describing it
now using these symbols and that kind of
gives some support to the idea that the
number really doesn't go beyond the
symbol we use for it and that goes by
the name either intuition ism or
constructivism that's actually really
big amongst computer scientists who
think of numbers not so much as
constructions in our mind but
constructions in a computer I think
we're in a bit of a bind when we come to
thinking about our knowledge of numbers
because I think numbers are real things
I think they're objective things so that
when I talk about the number 23 and when
you talk about the number 23 we're
talking about the same thing I don't
think the number 23 is something that we
could bump into in the street think that
it exists but it doesn't have a physical
presence in the world numbers don't bash
into each other like you know cars or
snooker balls do so the bind is
something like numbers are real
non-physical things on the other hand we
know about the world by physically
interacting with it that looks a bit
like saying we don't know about numbers
but I think do so here's one suggestion
about how we solve this problem and he
goes like this numbers are real things
they're out there in the world
they're non-physical things how do we
know about them we say that if it could
possibly exist it does exist
suppose we come up with some
mathematical theory we go through all
the axioms we check all the proofs and
we go oh yeah this is this
system.this look good so these numbers
all these things that our theory talks
about they could exist and then the
philosophy goes since it could exist it
does exist so we know that because our
theory is consistent the stuff it talks
about really does exist I can imagine a
lot of people who watch numberphile and
I like that just so something can exist
it does exist right and in general
that's just crazy right I mean Sherlock
Holmes could exist doesn't mean he does
exist but you might think the
mathematical entities because they're
not physical they don't take up any
space or time are different so the
mathematical universe seems to contain
all these weird and wonderful things and
it almost looks sometimes like we can
define things into existence we can say
things like let's define a group out of
sets as blah blah blah now how would
that work how could you just define
something into existence this theory has
an answer you're not making you exist
what that definition is doing is saying
it's possible for this thing to exist
and therefore it does exist that goes by
the name formalism the formalism is the
formal system of symbols that we write
down the axioms the proofs rules we set
ourselves to say that's a good proof
that's a bad proof once we've got those
symbols and we've got those rules hey
presto you've got the numbers
interestingly most of these questions
were originally raised by mathematicians
and they were raised in a time back in
the early 20th century where lots of
areas of maths had gone bad they
discovered the lots of the theories they
were using gave really weird and
contradictory results
it was paradoxes discovered in the
foundations of mathematics so one really
important concept was the concept of a
set this is an idea that came from
Cantor and Kant or thought well a set is
defined by a predicate like is tall is
tall defines the set of two people and
the idea was you give me a predicate
I'll give you a set but Bertrand Russell
in his famous paradox showed why that's
not going to work he said take the set
of all things that aren't members of
themselves that's a predicate if you try
and make a set out of it you get a
contradiction so established area of
mathematics we thought we knew it gives
us contradictions and the whole industry
based around making sure those paradoxes
went away really was a search for an
answer to the question how do we really
know about mathematics what the fiction
this has got to do is is try and explain
away the success of mathematics and the
success of science but without saying
that mathematical claims are true the
mathematical theory on the other hand
tells you bet whatever you've got stake
any amount of money you can get your
hands on